Notice that the Android TV home screen
displays games on a separate row
than apps.
To make your game appear here, as well
as to have it listed as an Android TV
game on the Google Play Store,
there's a couple quick updates we
need to make to your manifest.
First, we'll add this line to
indicate your app is a game.
Next, declare support for
game controllers.
And be sure to always set
the required flag to false,
even if your game requires one.
This might seem a bit counterintuitive.
And the reason is that game
pads are accessories and
they might not be connected
at the time of purchase.
So if you accidentally set
the required flag to true,
users might actually have trouble
installing your game from the Play Store
if their game controller
isn't connected.
If you actually do require a game pad,
instead just check if it's
connected when your game starts up.
As a refresher, carefully check your
manifest hardware requirements.
Also pay attention to implied
hardware requirements,
that can come about
because of permissions.
When you find a piece of hardware that's
supported on a mobile device, but
not a TV, like a sensor,
mark it as optional.
Then at runtime,
check what device you're running on, or
whether your device has a certain type
of hardware, before you try and use it.